This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Almost without fail, an architectural draft starts with one straight line, and then another, and another, a succession of clean orderly lines until eventually, a building emerges. And it makes sense that straight lines form the core of our built environment. They're cost-efficient, materials like wood and steel and pipes come in straight linear units, although that's a bit of a topology. But it's certainly easier to calculate structural loads
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。几乎毫无例外，建筑草图总是从一条直线开始，接着是另一条，再一条，一系列整洁有序的线条，直到最终，一座建筑浮现出来。直线构成我们建筑环境的核心是有道理的。它们具有成本效益，木材、钢材和管道等材料都是以直线单位供应的，尽管这有点拓扑学上的意味。但计算结构荷载确实更容易。
on rectilinear surfaces. Straight lines are logical, predictable. And they are completely devoid of humanity. So says producer Louisa Beck. Actually, it's not my argument. It's this guy's. The straight line is coldless and immoral. The straight line is not a creative line,
在直线表面上。直线是合乎逻辑的、可预测的。但它们完全缺乏人性。制片人路易莎·贝克如是说。其实，这不是我的观点。是这个人的。直线是无情的、不道德的。直线不是创造性的线条，
but an imitating line, a line line, a coward line. This is 1,000 sassar, Friedensreich, Regentag, Dunkelbund, 100 Wasser. In German, that means multi-talented piece filled rainy day dark colored 100 waters. It's a name he gave himself. Which makes sense because for 100 water, radical self expression was everything. Even tended on to buildings are subject to sensation. Such regulations are characteristic of prisons, cages and stables. This is from a speech Hunat Vasa gave in 1983
而是模仿的线条，是死板的线条，是懦弱的线条。这就是百水先生，弗里登斯赖希·百水。在德语中，这意味着多才多艺、充满雨天、深色调的百水。这是他给自己起的名字。这很有道理，因为对于百水来说，激进的自我表达就是一切。甚至连建筑也受到这种感觉的影响。这种规定是监狱、笼子和马厩的特征。这是百水在1983年发表的演讲，
at the Architectural Association in London. He was known for giving talks, wearing mismatched, wild colored socks and wacky hats, or showing up completely naked. That day, though, he was fully clothed. He looked out into a room full of architects and told them they were criminals, planning lifeless, rigid structures that restricted human creativity. The time has come for people to rebel against their confinement in duplicate constructions like prisoners or evidence in cages. A confinement which is alien to human nature.
在伦敦建筑协会。他以穿着不匹配、色彩鲜艳的袜子和古怪的帽子，或者完全赤身裸体地出现而闻名。不过那天，他穿戴整齐。他环顾满屋子的建筑师，告诉他们他们是罪犯，在规划毫无生气、僵化的结构，限制了人类的创造力。人们反抗被囚禁在重复的建筑中，像囚犯或笼子里的动物一样的时刻已经到来。这种禁锢违背了人性。
Hunalvasa was born Frédéric Stuvasa in 1928. He made a name for himself, so to speak, as a painter. He was known for squiggly, abstract, nearly psychedelic paintings. And in 1985, he completed a building, an apartment complex in his home city, Avanna. Hunter Rasser House looks as if one of his paintings had been made manifest. It's full of asymmetrical shapes, wacky colors, clashing patterns, mismatched windows, and unrelating uneven floors. There are no godless, straight lines inside.
百水原名弗里德里希·斯托瓦瑟，出生于1928年。他作为一名画家成名。他以蜿蜒、抽象、近乎迷幻的画作而闻名。1985年，他在家乡维也纳完成了一座公寓大楼。百水公寓看起来就像他的画作变成了现实。它充满了不对称的形状、古怪的颜色、冲突的图案、不匹配的窗户和不平整的地板。里面没有无情的直线。
Working together with architects and engineers, Hunat Vasa went on to design more buildings all over Vienna. His work really sticks out in that city, almost all the other buildings there are stately baroque. Throughout the 1980s and 90s, Hunat Vasa went on to design all kinds of other structures, like gas stations, heating plants, and schools. And his were known extended beyond Vienna. He was hired to design buildings in Germany, Japan, New Zealand. He made one building in the US, a winery in Nebavalle.
百水与建筑师和工程师合作，在维也纳设计了更多的建筑。他的作品在那个城市非常突出，因为那里几乎所有的其他建筑都是庄严的巴洛克风格。在整个20世纪80年代和90年代，百水设计了各种其他结构，如加油站、供热厂和学校。他的名声超出了维也纳。他受聘在德国、日本、新西兰设计建筑。他在美国也做过一个建筑，即纳帕谷的一家酒庄。
His architecture is fastuned with golden orbs and onion domes, zigzagging tiles, trees that grow out of apartment windows. He dreamed of creating indoor, moss-covered floors, though he was never able to get that approved. I think you get it. Hunter Vossar designed some crazy-looking buildings. Many architectural circles dismiss Hunter Vossar's work as Kitch. They look like buildings from Dr. Seuss or PV's playhouse or any number of children's cartoons. But Hundert Vassa actually got them built. And to him, they weren't just gimmicks.
他的建筑装饰着金色的球体和洋葱头圆顶、之字形的瓷砖，以及从公寓窗户长出来的树木。他梦想着创造室内覆盖苔藓的地板，尽管他从未获得批准。我想你明白了。百水设计了一些看起来很疯狂的建筑。许多建筑界人士将百水的作品斥为媚俗。它们看起来像是苏斯博士或皮威游乐场，或者许多儿童动画片里的建筑。但百水确实把它们建成了。对他来说，它们不仅仅是噱头。
Real people live in his buildings. He was trying to reframe what the built environment can be, to reimagine what architecture is supposed to do. Today architecture is criminalist. Today architecture is criminally sterile, he says. One of these Hunnadvasar buildings stands in Macdeburg, the city where I was born. Macdeburg is in what used to be communist East Germany,
真实的人住在他的建筑里。他试图重塑建筑环境的可能性，重新构想建筑应该做什么。他说，今天的建筑是犯罪性的，今天的建筑是犯罪性的贫瘠。其中一座百水建筑矗立在马格德堡，我出生的城市。马格德堡位于曾经的共产主义东德，
and it's one of those cities full of endless grids and straight lines. Its rows and rows of gray, Soviet-style apartment blocks and post-war architecture. Until you walk onto the main street in the city center and encounter this huge eight-story tall castle. And this castle is bright, pink salmon pink and it's decorated with brown tiled squiggles like big ceramic vines creeping up the pink walls There are almost 900 windows of all different shapes and sizes and 150 different lollipop looking columns hold up the building's floors on the roof hold up the building's floors. On the roof, eight golden spheres rise triumphantly, like sons over the dull homogenous blocks around them. Parts of the roof
它是那些充满无尽网格和直线的城市之一。到处都是灰色的苏联式公寓楼和战后建筑。直到你走进市中心的街道，遇到这座巨大的八层高城堡。这座城堡是明亮的粉红色，鲑鱼粉色，装饰着棕色的瓷砖蜿蜒图案，就像巨大的陶瓷藤蔓爬上粉红色的墙壁。有近900扇各种形状和大小的窗户，150根不同的棒棒糖形状的柱子支撑着建筑的楼层。在屋顶上，八个金色的球体胜利地升起，就像它们周围沉闷、同质化的街区之上的太阳。屋顶的部分
slope all the way down to the street and it's covered in trees. This is why, even though the building is mostly pink, it's called the Green Citadel. Residents of Maktable grappled with what to make of this gigantic, treetop salmon pink castle. Everyone has different opinions about it, including my grandparents, who live about a 20-minute walk from the Green Citadel in Moktaborg. I talked to them about it the last time I went back to visit. An annum stand ought to be better.
一直倾斜到街道，上面覆盖着树木。这就是为什么尽管这座建筑大部分是粉红色的，它却被称为“绿色城堡”。马格德堡的居民对这座巨大的、树顶鲑鱼粉色的城堡感到困惑。每个人对它都有不同的看法，包括我的祖父母，他们住在离马格德堡绿色城堡步行约20分钟的地方。我上次回去探望时和他们谈过。一个老人家说，
I have to say that I looks like a monkey house. I ask him why, and he grunts about the colorful facade and wavy surface. It just doesn't fit. But my grandma, she likes it. In fact, she likes to live in it. It breaks with the sameness that is so typical of East Germany. As my grandmother describes it, quote, the 40 communist years we lived in the same concrete high rises.
我不得不说它看起来像个猴子屋。我问他为什么，他嘟囔着彩色的外墙和波浪状的表面。它就是不协调。但我奶奶喜欢它。事实上，她喜欢住在里面。它打破了东德那种典型的千篇一律。正如我祖母所描述的那样，引用她的话：“我们生活在同样混凝土高楼里的那40年共产主义时期。”
And here is an apartment building that represents the uniqueness of each resident, and Hunatvasa realized this. In my opinion, she says, there should be more buildings like it. Too bad he passed away. Plans for the Green Citadel began in 1996 after the fall of the Berlin Wall. Hunter Vosser died in 2000 2000 while at sea on the QE2. The Green Citadel was completed five years later. 80% of the Green Citadel's covered in grass and the building has what Hunet Vassa called tree tenons, trees that were planted into special rooms inside of people's apartments. And his ideas about how to incorporate flora into buildings didn't stop with plants and trees. Hunatvasa was also really into mold, like the kind of mold that grows in the back of the fridge.
而这里有一栋公寓楼，代表了每个居民的独特性，百水意识到了这一点。她说，在我看来，应该有更多这样的建筑。可惜他去世了。绿色城堡的计划始于1996年柏林墙倒塌后。百水于2000年在伊丽莎白女王二号邮轮上航行时去世。绿色城堡五年后完工。绿色城堡80%的面积覆盖着草地，建筑拥有百水所谓的“树木租户”，即种植在人们公寓内特殊房间里的树木。他关于如何将植物融入建筑的想法并没有止步于植物和树木。百水也非常喜欢霉菌，就像冰箱后面长的那种霉菌。
When it all grows moldy, and the mold exhibits unusual patterns, or when moss grows over the geometric angus of the corner of your house, together with mushrooms and vegetation, life moves into a sterile house. And as delightful as Hunter Vossars warped in kaleidoscopic buildings are, the exaltation of mold is where he and I part ways. At least we know he didn't suffer from allergies.
当一切都发霉时，霉菌呈现出不寻常的图案，或者当苔藓长在房子角落的几何角度上，连同蘑菇和植被一起，生命就进入了一个贫瘠的房子。尽管百水的扭曲和万花筒般的建筑令人愉悦，但对霉菌的推崇是我和他分道扬镳的地方。至少我们知道他没有过敏症。
Instead of TV, it is better to watch nature grow wild and grow out of human control. For instance, in the case of spontaneous vegetation. Oh boy. Hunant Vasa was big on manifestos. He had another one that he called, and I'm not making this up, the holy s**t manifesto. Every time we use the flash toilet, we think it is an hygienic accomplishment. But in fact, we violate the laws of nature.
与其看电视，不如看大自然野蛮生长，脱离人类的控制。例如，在自发植被的情况下。天哪。百水非常热衷于宣言。他还有另一个宣言，我不是在编造，叫作“神圣的排泄宣言”。每次我们使用抽水马桶，我们都认为这是一种卫生成就。但事实上，我们违反了自然法则。
We pray before we eat and we say grace afterwards. But we do not pray when we s**t. Everything taking humans away from nature or any of our natural processes was in a front to Hunter Vossar. So his buildings were designed to keep us more in touch with our disgusting organic reality. If we do not treasure our sh** and if we do not transform it into humus, in honor of God and the world, we lose our right to be present on this earth.
我们在吃饭前祈祷，饭后做感恩祷告。但我们在排泄时并不祈祷。任何将人类从自然或我们的任何自然过程中剥离出来的东西，对百水来说都是一种冒犯。所以他的建筑旨在让我们更多地接触我们恶心的有机现实。如果我们不珍惜我们的排泄物，如果我们不把它转化为腐殖质，以纪念上帝和世界，我们就失去了在这个地球上存在的权利。
Humus is the part of the soil that's rich and dark with organic matter. Who in advance have proposed to plan natural urine purification systems and compost toilets in his buildings? Although his investors wouldn't back indoor compost toilets in the green citadel, when Luisa was last in Germany, she talked her way into the building. This is the shower that he put in for the bathroom they used blue tiles as a room. And also there's no straight lines here either. Oh, none.
腐殖质是土壤中富含深色有机物质的部分。百水提议在他的建筑中规划天然尿液净化系统和堆肥厕所。尽管他的投资者不支持绿色城堡里的室内堆肥厕所，但路易莎上次在德国时，她设法进入了那栋建筑。这就是他为浴室安装的淋浴间，他们用了蓝色瓷砖作为房间。而且这里也没有直线。哦，一点也没有。
None. I visited a bathroom in the green citadel. I didn't see any composting toilets. I didn't even see any mold. What I did see though were crazy patterns. Let me just feel, look at this. You have like round corners all over the apartment. There are no like sharp and crisp corners here. Nicole Zanda and her partners Abastan live in the green citadel.
一点也没有。我参观了绿色城堡的一间浴室。我没有看到任何堆肥厕所。我甚至没有看到任何霉菌。但我看到的是疯狂的图案。让我感受一下，看看这个。公寓里到处都是圆角。这里没有那种尖锐、干脆的角落。妮可·赞达和她的伴侣塞巴斯蒂安住在绿色城堡里。
Like you said, we have two bathrooms, one with the tub and one with just a shower. The bathroom tiles are staggered and slightly shifted sideways so that they don't line up and columns. In some places, they're tilted diagonally or shattered and their fragments put back together to form a unique mosaic-like pattern. They showed me around their place. You see, this is a different kind of window.
就像你说的，我们有两个浴室，一个有浴缸，一个只有淋浴。浴室瓷砖是交错的，稍微向侧面移动，这样它们就不会排成列。在某些地方，它们是斜着放置的，或者被打碎，碎片重新组合在一起，形成独特的马赛克图案。他们带我参观了他们的地方。你看，这是一种不同的窗户。
It opens up all the way, and it's got that round on top of it. Now we'll get into the parts of Hunter Vosser's manifesto-laden worldview that is blissfully free of mold and excrement and appeals to our sense of individuality. For Honehadeva said, the goal was to construct a creative lifestyle for the people who lived and worked in and around the Green Citadel. He designed the building to encourage residents, individuality to shine forth.
它完全打开，上面是圆形的。现在我们要进入百水那充满宣言的世界观中，那些令人愉快地没有霉菌和排泄物，并吸引我们个性感的部分。因为百水说，目标是为在绿色城堡内外生活和工作的人们构建一种创造性的生活方式。他设计这座建筑是为了鼓励居民的个性闪耀出来。
And it wasn't just in terms of how he built the Green Citadel. Part of it were the rules that govern day. The apartment house had must have the freedom to lean out of this window and as far as its arms can reach to change the outside walls of its buildings. Hunat was the encouraged residents to lean out of their windows and paint the facade around them any color and design they wanted. He called this concept Fenstachricht or right of window. When he says prisoners, he's referring to you and me. The idea was close your second skin, your home is your third skin. And if we choose our own clothes, why shouldn't renters choose the colors for their outside walls, at least around the window?
这不仅仅体现在他建造绿色城堡的方式上。部分原因在于管理日常的规则。公寓房必须有自由，可以从窗户探出身子，尽可能伸出手臂，改变建筑的外墙。百水鼓励居民探出窗户，把周围的外墙漆成他们想要的任何颜色和设计。他称这个概念为“窗户权”。当他说囚犯时，他指的是你和我。这个想法是，你的第二层皮肤，你的家是你的第三层皮肤。如果我们选择自己的衣服，为什么租房者不能选择外墙的颜色，至少在窗户周围？
Hunter Vossar believed that residents painting their windows, their homes, would be a form of their own self-expression. He wasn't explicitly demanding that residents lean out their windows and their homes, would be a form of their own self-expression. He wasn't explicitly demanding that residents lean out their windows and paint the borders around them, but he was hoping to design an environment that would encourage them to do it of their own free will. I asked Sebastian and Nicole the Greensett Adel residents if they thought about taking him up on his right of window idea. So far, only one person has taken Hunaed Vasa up on the right of window here, and the
百水相信，居民粉刷他们的窗户和家，将是一种自我表达的形式。他并没有明确要求居民探出窗户，但这将是他们自我表达的一种形式。他并没有明确要求居民探出窗户，粉刷周围的边框，但他希望设计一种环境，鼓励他们出于自由意志去做这件事。我问绿色城堡的居民塞巴斯蒂安和妮可，他们是否考虑过采纳他的“窗户权”想法。到目前为止，只有一个人在这里采纳了百水的“窗户权”，而且
modifications were pretty minor. The building manager told me that he hasn't received a single application from anyone else requesting to paint the exterior facade around their window to exercise their fence to right. We took a quick poll here in the office and both Sam and I would feel a little too intimidated to have hazardly paint the outside of our window on an already amazing building. Avery would be leaning outside to paint on day one, and Katie would be out there on a window washer's rig painting up a storm in a hot minute.
修改非常小。大楼经理告诉我，他没有收到任何其他人申请粉刷窗户周围外墙以行使他们的“窗户权”的请求。我们在办公室做了一个快速民意调查，我和萨姆都觉得有点太胆怯了，不敢在一座已经很棒的建筑上随意粉刷窗户外面。艾弗里第一天就会探出身子去粉刷，而凯蒂会立刻坐在洗窗工的吊篮上，疯狂地粉刷。
I generally love the right of window idea, even if I wouldn't necessarily participate, but it also feels a little like forced fun. Like being required to take a day off of work to play wacky games with their co-workers on a company retreat or audience participation that stick to their theater or having a pop album appear automatically on your phone. It's mainly fun for people designing the experience. That's the irony in all of this. Who knew as a fought against architectural doctrine so that people could be free to express themselves. But only as he wanted them to. In many ways, in addition to being brilliant objects of art,
我通常很喜欢“窗户权”的想法，即使我不一定会参与，但它也感觉有点像被迫的乐趣。就像被要求请一天假，在公司务虚会上和同事玩古怪的游戏，或者强加给观众的互动，或者手机上自动出现的流行专辑。这主要是为了设计体验的人而设计的乐趣。这就是这一切的讽刺之处。谁知道百水反对建筑教条是为了让人们可以自由地表达自己。但只能按照他想要的方式。在许多方面，除了作为杰出的艺术品，
Hunter Vosser's buildings were like concept cars or high fashion. A three-wheeled car with a bubble roof or six-foot tall for hats are not meant for the mats market, but radical concepts move to norm forward. You certainly do not want a house for the mold. You really don't. It's terrible. But just try to find an urbanist these days, who is not all for green roofs. And that's what the big talking naked speech-giving manifesto writers of the world are for. 99% Invisible Was Produced This Week by Luisa Beck with Avery Troubleman Sam Greenspan Katie Mingle and me Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7 local public radio KALW in San Francisco and produced in beautiful downtown Oakland, California, out of the offices
百水的建筑就像概念车或高级时装。带有泡泡车顶的三轮车或六英尺高的皮草帽子不是为大众市场准备的，但激进的概念推动了规范向前发展。你当然不想要一个有霉菌的房子。你真的不想要。那太可怕了。但试着找一个当代的城市规划师，看看谁不支持绿色屋顶。这就是世界上那些大声说话、裸体演讲、撰写宣言的人的意义所在。《99%隐形》本周由路易莎·贝克制作，艾弗里·特鲁布尔曼、萨姆·格林斯潘、凯蒂·明格尔和我罗曼·马尔斯参与。我们是旧金山91.7地方公共广播电台KALW的一个项目，在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心制作，出自
of ArcSide, who we check in with on so many of our stories. I think it's a reaction to Eastern European Soviet block style architecture. This makes a lot of sense when you look at it. What I want to see this become the norm probably not, but I think it's always healthy to have a variety of things. This is about a city who has the foresight to say, yeah, these art pieces as architecture are important. I shudder to think at the number of little mistakes we would make if we didn't have Adam and Daniel and the whole crude arc sign
ArcSide的办公室，我们在许多故事中都会与他们核对。我认为这是对东欧苏联集团风格建筑的一种反应。当你审视它时，这很有道理。我是否希望看到这成为常态？可能不会，但我认为拥有多样化的事物总是健康的。这是关于一个城市有远见地说，是的，这些作为建筑的艺术品很重要。我不敢想象，如果我们没有亚当、丹尼尔和整个ArcSide团队
at the desks right next to us to answer our questions. Oh my god. Thanks for being there, guys. Radio Tapio. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在隔壁桌子上回答我们的问题，我们会犯多少小错误。天哪。谢谢你们在那里。Radio Tapio。来自PRX。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。